-Performing "Tacones Rojos,"
from his multi-platinum
new album, "Dharma," please
welcome Sebastian Yatra!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Es una voz ♪
♪ Hay un rayo de luz ♪
♪ Que entró por mi ventana ♪
♪ Y me ha devuelto las ganas ♪
♪ Me quita el dolor ♪
♪ Tu amor es uno de esos ♪
♪ Que te cambian con un beso ♪
♪ Y te pone a volar ♪
♪ Mi pedazo de sol ♪
♪ La niña de mis ojos ♪
♪ Tiene una colección ♪
♪ De corazones rotos ♪
♪ Mi pedazo de sol ♪
♪ La niña de mis ojos ♪
♪ La que baila reggaetón ♪
♪ Con tacones rojos
y me pone a volar ♪
♪ La que me hace llorar ♪
♪ La que me hace sufrir ♪
♪ Pero no paro de amar ♪
♪ Porque me hizo sentir ♪
♪ Que gane la lotería ♪
♪ Antes de ella no sabía que
alguien podía amarme así ♪
♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ♪
-♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
-What's up, U.S.A.?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ El día que te conocí, lo
sentí, me deje llevar ♪
♪ Me morí,
reviví en el mismo bar ♪
♪ Solo entraba
para emborracharme, ey ♪
♪ No esperaba enamorarme de ti ♪
♪ Ni tú de mí ♪
♪ Y pasó así ♪
♪ Y así empezó
nuestra historia ♪
♪ No falla mi memoria ♪
♪ Yo te dije "baby ♪
♪ ¿Qué haces tú por aquí? ♪
♪ Así empezó nuestra historia
Y te lleve pa Colombia ♪
♪ Mi pedazo de sol ♪
♪ La niña de mis ojos ♪
♪ Tiene una colección ♪
♪ De corazones rotos ♪
♪ Mi pedazo de sol ♪
♪ La niña de mis ojos ♪
♪ La que baila reggaetón ♪
♪ Con tacones rojos
y me pone a volar ♪
♪ La que me hace llorar ♪
♪ La que me hace sufrir ♪
♪ Pero no paro de amar ♪
♪ Porque me hizo sentir ♪
♪ Que gane la lotería ♪
♪ Antes de ella no sabía que
alguien podía amarme así ♪
-♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah, ah ♪
-♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
-♪ Me cuidas entre tu ventana ♪
♪ Y así empezó, ya ves ♪
♪ Mi pedazo de sol ♪
♪ La niña de mis ojos ♪
♪ Tiene una colección ♪
♪ De corazones rotos ♪
♪ Mi pedazo de sol ♪
♪ La niña de mis ojos ♪
♪ La que baila reggaetón ♪
♪♪
♪ Y me pone a volar ♪
♪ La que me hace llorar ♪
♪ La que me hace sufrir ♪
♪ Pero no paro de amar ♪
♪ Porque me hizo sentir ♪
♪ Que gané la lotería ♪
♪ Antes de ella no sabía que
alguien podía amarme así ♪
♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah, ah ♪
♪♪
-♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
-♪ Ah, ah ah, ah ah, ah ah ♪
-♪ Mi pedazo de sol,
yeah, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]